I'm here to show my boyfriend what a
bloody pad looks like I've had my period
for about 11 years and that's roughly
2,600 used menstrual products that I've
had in my lifetime Steve has seen maybe
six if I did a good job of hiding them
my knowledge of women's ovulation is
pretty I would consider it average for
men whenever in my period I definitely
don't in other room in terms of the
bloody side of things I try to hide it
from him most of the time I think it's
just been ingrained in my system that
it's an embarrassing thing to have your
period I mean I grew up with one sister
but my sister was pretty good at hiding
that part of her I think I'm probably
anymore
embarrassed for him to see it Benzies
going to be so this is a pad from sort
of the end of my period so I'd say it's
a little bit of a lighter flow did I do
it all right here we go
all right Oh Oh God Oh My giddy I'm
kidding come on okay
I mean he probably dissected worse for
some reason I was imagining you were
gonna hold up like like a small Ziploc
like filled to the brim with blood and I
wouldn't even be able to I don't know
why I know that's not even pop I mean
the maybe that's possible
[Music]
so over the course of like a Puri that
you have if you're wearing a pad is this
the normal amount this is lighter I keep
turning it over expecting to see
something new
[ __ ] so I was imagining I was imagining
like blood-red like what you imagine the
reddest of the red to be
[Music]
[Music]
it's sad how like when I first got my
period how ashamed I was feeling about
it because guys used to give me [ __ ] for
tampons and pads didn't even have blood
on them like I would have to like subtly
hide it in my shirt when I went to the
bathroom I just think that's so weird
when it's such a natural thing that we
go through I'm very relieved that
Steve's handled it so maturely what I
learned through this actually had less
to do with the pad itself then learning
what your thoughts were like going into
it that you have been more uncomfortable
than I even realized I would say I'm
relieved that Steve has seen it up close
I think there's a way to be still
respectful and not wanting to see this
like if you're dating somebody and you
accidentally have a period that gets the
same somewhere I think there's a way to
be nice about it and still be honest
fear what if I just vomited on the table
that would have been I would have had a
lot of therapy to get through
[Music]